this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is another sold-out Saturday night
here in Hollywood so let's babble the
[ __ ] out I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph
Garman
all right you lovely you're so kind not
seen this many people in one room since
this afternoon I went to the opening
ceremony for the LA Kings Psalm raised
the bow caught a lot of [ __ ] on Twitter
people know you're supposed to like the
devil's you pray again as if we live in
a comic book world of like they're the
good guys and they're the bad guys well
the good guys are the Flyers and
everyone else is a bad guys like Ed like
that ever happened
this was my feeling any franchise in the
NHL particularly raise the one out here
that I [ __ ] live out here they raise
a banner for the first time their first
Stanley Cup like that's a win for hockey
in general yeah that's right
having the Kings win was really great
for this city last year when I was sad
for me as I was a devil spam but the
same time I could be like this is great
look how happy everybody is he got
everybody charged up and energized about
hockey just in time for there to be a
lockout and then yeah well you win the
sit and wait and have no hockey for
happy you would not have known it today
man there was no evidence of bitterness
and [ __ ] were people like [ __ ] the
lockup people were just so happy to
watch the game they got their rings
Tiffany made their rings and I saw when
I had my hands I [ __ ] huge Tiffany I
think we're alone now Tiffany yeah yeah
that's what she's doing now I've never
worked in a while so she put him
together she's bottling up some [ __ ]
tinfoil and they were really nice that's
great but they were beautiful do their
[ __ ] that bigger and Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] this much around let me write that
one down will you hit that later I saw
that I Sutton then I saw him raise the
banner place went [ __ ] nuts you
couldn't fit any more people in the
Staples today it was really really great
man and then what a storybook beginning
to the day and they showed their [ __ ]
clip reel of like their cup
yes I just sit there and watch him beat
the Devils again and [ __ ]
and then they raise their banner and I
went and played the Hawks and everything
the wheels just [ __ ] came off yeah I
felt so bad for him cuz everyone was
like it's our day until the actual puck
drop that people like [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah until they got their rings and [ __ ]
and they were like [ __ ] you with your
fancy rings and then I watched the
Devils play [ __ ] could they play the
Islanders very memorable game and they
won and then your team played today's I
played the Pens did not do so well today
they announced Sabres tomorrow very
exciting dev hi it is nice f hockey back
man I come a lot of people in America
like who gives a [ __ ]
well I do I do also very exciting news I
was gonna save this for geek news but I
can't because I'm too geeked about it
just just got word the TV Batmobile the
1966 TV Batmobile the one that Adam West
sweet ass was sitting in for three
seasons yup just sold at auction this
evening it
Barrett Jackson's auto auction in
Scottsdale Arizona this is the og the
George Barris well this is the one this
is the hero card which they were saying
it's gonna go for upwards of a million
bucks yeah once you quadruple that son I
thought you were doing your Herman
Munster impression for a second I was
just like you got a new water dog dogs
over door 4.2 million dollars like say I
am the happy not owner of that car
you know how to buy that a [ __ ] a
billionaire like Oh Bruce Wayne but he
charged it to his business so no one
could put the two together and then he
put it in a cave and smart yeah and then
he quit great year yeah and then [ __ ]
Joe gordon-levitt found it that's right
yeah
no it's very exciting that one dude was
like why and then [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off all by jumping on it
you [ __ ] about they're all Brad yeah
she [ __ ] me she [ __ ] me I figured I
got around my waist and me lovely
singing voice ooh that
alright let's kick off the show as we do
every week by saying hello to some
people have come particularly long
distances or celebrating special
occasions in the house the section we
call the shout outs round so get your
[ __ ] out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know Malcolm Gladwell's like 10,000
hours of practice somebody good at
anything's right in my old age when I'm
in my 70s you'll be able to hire me out
at weddings and I'll fellate microphones
yeah because that's what every wedding
needs really is a guy will blow a
microphone who is that old fat man he
made clerks once now it just sucks off
sound equipment looking for Joe and his
wife they're there rables mom and daddy
you guys here where are you guys right
down front their drunken up front just
the way we like it
rabble rabble never would have guessed
from this never will
Rab e al Rebell well he can't be here
tonight he said he or she he okay got
that much right he can't be here tonight
but he wrote us from Whittier California
he said my name is rebel I will not be
at the show but my stepdad Joe and we'll
be there with my mother celebrating his
birthday and it would I would really
appreciate if he take a few moments to
let me tell him how much he means to me
can we all music I'll do a little Casey
Kasem for this one I think
when I was four years old my mom brought
home a drummer whose mom didn't really
know who took his time to look at all my
toys and talk to me about Star Wars and
Batman and other things he would drive
to our house in Norwalk after he got off
work and Boyle Heights just to help me
with my homework
just after I turned seven they got
married and ever since then he's helped
me with my homework my Halloween
costumes my school projects and most of
all treated me like his own flesh and
blood
I am 18 now and he is still a huge part
of my life I will never be able to thank
him for all the things he has done for
me but maybe the McDonald's fry girl
could think of a few things
happy birthday dad love you rebel so
that's for you Joe from your son rubella
your good man sir you won't remember
this until you hear the podcast cuz
you're like I'm dry you're a great day
you were better than a happy Neil stupid
eyes flies you better think shamrock
shake
but you're not better than McRib no it's
very cool of you sir to step up and be a
dad to him to another man I appreciate
that he's 18 now he's a man
oh I've misread that letter completely
man how about Rob and Robbie are you
guys in the house tonight
Rob Robbie and his horizon Rob L it's
Rob and his 18-year old son Robbie oh my
god what is going on man family's bond
over Babylon I do we bring people
together even families who have limited
selections of names Rob and Robbie it
really just just stopped it Rob the
whole family said that's enough free hey
Rob what's good enough for me
[ __ ] it's good enough for you
I'm the father of three and a huge fan
of you guys writes Rob being responsible
father that I am I've turned my sons
onto HBO we listen every week tonight
I'm bringing my eldest son Robbie to the
show to celebrate his 18th birthday
could have got him laid sir just saying
there were options yes that's next yeah
I know he would appreciate advice on how
to be a man from Edwin do you think you
can make that happen
thanks Rob oh my goodness of course I
could let me tell you all about being a
man don't you know the most important
thing about being a man is to have a
manly voice I've always found this voice
of mine gets all the ladies
[Music]
lights for the living but Morgan and
Tommy and Ashley and Dominic and Andrey
and Steve my husband Tom and I'll be
attending our Babylon to celebrate his
28th birthday we were popping the
cherries of for HBO virgins ashley
dominic andrea and steve speaking of
virgins i was wondering if ralph could
do a special shout out to my husband for
his birthday we've been together for
over 11 years and even though we've been
getting it on since we were 16 there are
still areas of our relationship yet to
be explored so for his birthday I would
like christopher walken to let my
husband know that tonight my naughty
orange navel is all his he's gonna [ __ ]
her in the stomach that's what I thought
initially this I don't even know about
so you could do that to me I can [ __ ] a
double this [ __ ] over like a pair of
titties you can slam that [ __ ] home man
look at you in fleshlight yeah I'm
assuming what is that yeah what is it
what are you talking about
you know is that Morgan yeah I'm letting
him take my ass tonight
I'm assuming it's the shrinker gotta be
right Wow so wait after how many years
together 11 years you've kept it this
long Chris Walken letting you know Tommy
that you're gonna get the knotty orange
navel this Babylon brought to you by
Sunkist oh my goodness
good news for you Tommy you're getting
ass
I think can't really be sure because the
naval could be the stomach or the ass
probably the stomach congratulations
Tommy enjoy that won't you Donny and
Craig Donnie and Craig are you guys here
greetings yeah we're here what about it
[ __ ] Daria is here man yeah we're
here drunken fat guy yeah
greetings from the Silicon Valley
community and it's not a country it's
it's up in California I think or is that
a euphemism for the ass to Silicon
Valley
my name is Donny my boyfriend's name is
Craig you can spot us in the crowd as
the asian chick with the huge rack and
the irish man with a magnificent beard
that is a pretty good pretty good she's
got a good could see that from
Commissioner Gordon's office actually if
you put those up in the sky if Batman
had those Joker would have killed them
long ago such an easy shot we're both
broke ass film students who managed to
book a train ride a cheap hotel and
tickets to the show tonight you took the
train down from Silicon Valley oh that's
a six-hour bus ride and then three hours
on the train how much did that cost man
cuz you probably gonna like rented a car
that sounds like a lot of public transit
was it free next totally free how did
you know what did it cost two hundred
smalls if you were a piece for both you
round-trip 216 yeah you could have
rented a car yeah
a wrench of my car for half you could
have gone on Craigslist and found a
drifter just carry you on his back for
that kind of money can you and Kevin
Smith and do me a favor
I love when people use my full name yeah
as opposed to the other Kevin is here
can you sign my chest rights Donny to
kregasm remembrance for our first big
date let me try no not not a that
American sign language I think she means
signing her tits how does that how does
that commemorate your big date with
Craig by having me and Kevin sign your
tits it's a trophy for us it's not
trophy for him on the day you want to
take to Craig so it's like a gift from
us to Craig we're giving him your tits
Jesus Christ
it's an autograph on her boobs it's like
an areola graph or something like that
you sign it to him but she holds on to
it you'll be helping me leave one hell
of an impression yeah that your your
your crazy [ __ ] who wants people to sign
your tips their first big date and she
wants us to sign her Kate yeah I would
make an impression hey we'll get to it
later how about that we'll get this you
don't mind
it's a cuckold kind of thing going on
now oh did you give us permission and
sure yeah all right he's got to that's
one apiece I'm gonna sign the naval
orange
we also get emails from all the way
around the world James
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions this first
email comes from listener Ron H who
writes congratulations to Kevin he's
finally arrived he included this
photograph this comes from the website
of wick of a vivid entertainment they
finally made an x-rated porn parody of
clerks buddy soon in a couple of weeks
buddy of mine just want a pair of golden
globes for some stupid movie he made or
whatever but this is the grandest prize
of all
I don't see the xxx Argo parody anywhere
it would be called of course and by the
way this is this is silent Bertha right
here she is inspired by your character
my tits are way bigger yeah that is cool
though dude I always went back a few
years
let me Xin to the career where by the
time chasing Amy came out man where's
our porn parody but our movies are too
small to be noticed but you stick around
long enough kids they will make a porn
parody of your [ __ ] and a girl will play
you the premise barely it's they flipped
it it's two girls and instead of working
at a convenience store they work at a
porn shop and Jane and silent Bertha who
hang outside the porn shop instead of
being drug dealers are prostitutes there
goes my [ __ ] script add some
prostitutes nice
this next emails from Brad Peterson from
Des Moines Iowa he says big and a big
fan since the beginning I was talking my
friend Nicole today was watching an
episode of bewitched starring Adam West
that's one of my favorite episodes as
you can imagine you love to be winched I
love people I like poets for what
episode was he on plays one of the this
is after Batman he played one of the
clients that Darren brings home from the
advertising firm plays a character named
Kermit
Brad says Nicole and I were talking
being both big fans of Adam West and the
Muppets we decided would be awesome if
Adam West would sing the Rainbow
Connection as Kermit the Frog
it's a bit of a stretch yeah that's an
impression of an impression but I'm game
so here we go at the Rainbow Connection
doom-doom doom-doom to do why are there
so many songs about rainbows and what's
on the other side missions but just
illusions and rainbows have nothing to
hide so we've been told and some choose
to believe it but I know they're wrong
wait and see someday we'll find it The
Rainbow Connection the lovers the
dreamers there we go just got a little
choked up and that was like one of the
saddest songs movies sad and not in a
way of like you know my children are
dead it's just such a like a wailing
song it's just so insanely touching yeah
it's about dreaming and shooting I love
this day Mariah Evans writes a few weeks
ago ended up with a at the vet with my
14 year old dog Henry he's had cancer
for the pet I think we need some sad
Hope Christ man
first the sad frog song now the dead dog
this works out yeah dog comes back from
the dead sometimes dead is better a few
weeks ago I ended up at the vet with my
14 year old dog Henry yet cancer for the
past three years
okay that's worse than the Frey girl
thing you are going to hell ending I can
laugh because it's a good ending man he
started looking
you're [ __ ] mean one mr. Grinch he's
at Kent he's at Cub so for the past what
he started live Peggy we thought it had
spread to his bones while I waited for
the results of the vet my dog and I
listened to Hollywood babble-on to keep
me calm why are we laughing it kept me
laughing while I felt like crying thank
you guys for your podcast and for
bringing lots of laughs to my life
Henry's doing much better now
no thanks to Ralph and all my worrying
was for nothing now I listen to the new
podcast with Henry but I noticed
something strange that he does in here
so well anymore [ __ ] this dog man
everything out of his [ __ ] broken and
[ __ ] my dog Lucky 14 cut Henry a break
yes I going an old RV he doesn't hear so
well anymore but when Kevin does his
creepy sexy voice hey hardness he gets
up and stares at the music player and
wags his tail
I thought it was odd enough to write
into you guys could Ralph get Kevin to
talk dirty to my dog thanks for all the
fun
Mariah Evan yes so for Henry the 14 year
old hard-of-hearing cancer dog could you
please talk dirty to him well he'll be
happy and wag his tail I'm only
considering this because I have an old
dog to man and I know like you know
there's not much you could do for him
but talk them off I guess that's right
Henry oh let me see your red thing he's
a [ __ ] dog say [ __ ] you won't know
what I mean a red thing they like I got
one of those I want to put on my filthy
clown makeup n ring see you in doggy
that's a [ __ ] good thing with a dog
go good dog good dog [ __ ] done
lastly this is from Carl and Annie
Belson in Vancouver BC Monday will be
our fifth anniversary to celebrate my
wife Annie has announced she'll be
letting me make a delivery in the rear
loading dock boy our people just love
the ass however she's asked the David
Bowie serenade her to get her in the
mood please help us make this special
day a memorable one Karl Nanny belston
never like when it comes to finally
giving it up after years and years it's
weird that they want you involved I know
well to be honest nothing is more erotic
or romantic than me doing a bad David
Bowie impression while you fondle
yourself
weird - Mel look they're asking for it
this is for Annie and Carl having anal
sex in Vancouver James congratulations
column and he's going to give you her
sphincter you're gonna stick it in her
[ __ ] congratulations
Garo you're going to take her butthole
congratulations
it's time for rainbow says you pin with
above five years and now she will bend
over she's going to give you perspective
you're going to be well no one
[Music]
I was fine he started catching it then I
I like to call the circle of life and
last week we debuted a new segment
called the Green Lantern oath we went
over very well
yes people seem to like it so we're
gonna try it again this week this is a
segment where I do the legendary green
and turn Green Lantern ring to lose URLs
there buddy
[Applause]
the Green Lantern oath that he says
while he's recharging his power ring in
the voice of one of our listeners your
[ __ ] Green Lantern
[Music]
[Music]
this week's request comes from Steven in
Kansas City listeners since the
beginning so many obvious choices for
the Green Lantern oath he writes but
last after last week I absolutely need
to hear Huell Howser write Green Lantern
bow I was shocked at the response we got
for Huell because he is sort of a local
phenomenon here in Southern California I
think that works if you know him but I
think if you're from outside the area
like that just sounds funny lots of
people I turned to Huell onto them last
week so this guy in Kansas City wants to
hear Huell Howser recharging his battery
ring than reciting the Green Lantern's
oath in brightest day or blackest night
no evil shall escape my sight let those
who worship evils might beware my power
Green Lantern's light
this is amazing
rest in peace you'll he could have been
a good green liner to Huell he was all
he's all buff and gay and whatnot Slavic
Domino mask on him he's there that's
right every week like say goodbye to
some people had the legendary careers in
show business who have left us this week
they deserve a proper send-off and
that's why we do the Tinseltown snips
[Music]
they will be missed this week we lost
Jimmy O'Neal Jimmy was the host of a
short-lived but powerful TV series in
the 60s called shindig and shindig was
like an American Bandstand type show yes
but they featured the hottest acts of
the 60s from 1964 to 1966 he was one of
these guys he was in LA deejay who
happened to end up hosting this show and
I was fascinated by people who end up in
the center of a of a pop culture storm
you know he wasn't a musician he didn't
sing songs or write songs but he was at
the center of the music world for just a
brief moment in the 60s his show
introduced American teenagers to bands
like The Who The Beatles The Mamas in
the Papas the Righteous Brothers this
Rolling Stones it was an amazing show
and he was an excellent host passed away
this week at the age of 72 here's this
little taste of his work from the TV
series shindig Jimmy O'Neill well here
they are
America's number one group Al Jardine
Mike Love
Carl Dennis and Brian we'll see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are those girls screaming about the
Beach Boys are big dorks yeah they're
bunch of dorks people watch that footage
like they're all fat doughy guys over
girls screaming for them that was our
time no we would have been stars totally
yeah now we live in a world of buff tan
guys any wire fans in the house tonight
show the wire one of the stars of that
show Robert f Chu passed away this week
at the age of 52 he was known for
playing the drug kingpin proposition Joe
remember prop Joe here's a shot of
Robert at work he was a big boy he died
at the age of 52 from heart failure he
was a local Baltimore actor they shot
the series there in Baltimore as well
correct
he used to have a theater group for
inner-city kids in Baltimore but he was
also an actor and he started working on
homicide first at a couple shots on that
and then they cast him on the wire when
they were shooting in Baltimore and his
career was sort of made by that show he
could have moved to Los Angeles for New
York and got more work but he stayed
behind and taught those kids until his
death he taught kids inner-city kids
about theater and music and stuff like
that and lastly one of everybody's
favorite TV dads conrad bain passed away
this week
he was the dad on Diff'rent Strokes he
was the rich dad we all wanted man he
was mr. Drummond yeah the rich white guy
who raised two young black kids as if
they were his own would she talk about
mr. Drummond Arnold and Willis were the
kids yeah he is also on Maude he had a
great career in television he was a
big-time theatre actor as well
originally from Alberta Canada he was
Canadian I did not know this he was
survived by his daughter and two sons
and also his twin brother boner
phoner Bane gon AR and boner was his
name-o how would one pronounce that I
choose to pronounce it boner boner may
be boner boner boner babe like a
colorful character right there man
owner ban is the human flesh light
he was good dad man he was one of the
great TV was I really enjoyed him and he
always liked when he came across
adolescent because he always whipped a
little knowledge on him at the end you
scared me there for a minute
he always whipped him I was like that's
racially insensitive right there sir
whenever he imparted the wisdom man like
there was a stern tone to his voice but
very accepting this moment here's a
moment from one of the episodes I
brought in some tape of Conrad Bain
where this final in the episode where he
officially adopts Willis and Arnold and
they tell him that they're looking
forward to as much as he is when the
adoption becomes final Friday if you
don't mind well we like to call you dead
dad you want to call me Dad if it's all
right with you if it's all right if it's
all right you made a dream come true
I've always wanted a boy now I got two
of them yeah then he brought the bicycle
shop owner over and they all what
happened yeah what the doctor was fired
the bicycle shop owner came over and
then it was tough on the bike shop owner
if you remember that episode he went in
there guns blazing yeah he was just like
I've got enough money to you know dot
dot dot don't make me call boner said
there was a on eclis an episode of sctv
do you ever watch s each year is he he
guess he guest hosted one episode and
they played this thing where he was his
brother Hank bang and they were doing on
SCTV they're knockoff of Diff'rent
Strokes and stuff so they couldn't get
comrade brain so they got his brother so
weird that he had a real twin brother or
a twin yeah twin brother boner
I'm never gonna stop do you think you
like he did his stunts and [ __ ] was he
like a stump boner all the stunts on
Diff'rent Strokes yeah I think he did
all the different stroke stunts okay
we're gonna go in for a hug in this
scene boner boner baby please you dog
the black kids okay thanks
apparently he died of heart failure but
they say the camera bait also suffered
from several different strokes before he
passed away why I'm reporting the news
you keep it on like news apparently
that's the problem how dare you sir this
week we also take a look at some
big-time showbiz people who can get out
of the way of their own egos and do
something nice for somebody else the
segment we call Hollywood helpers
[Music]
there's any song with a beat just make
you touch yourselves
I'm like the girl in Flashdance pull a
cord later on only it's not water
this is it it's tragic but it's cool I
don't mean it's tragic cause that's cool
I mean it's tragic slash that's gonna be
your [ __ ] biography it's tragic but
it's cool the Ralph Garman
angry the 14 year old dog it's a bad
side but it's a good side to last week
in Taft California may have heard there
was yet another school shooting
yes there were many people injured now
the one victim beau Cleveland apparently
is going to be okay he's going to mend
sixteen-year-old Taft Union High School
student was injured in the shooting but
he is currently in the hospital
apparently he is recovering well thing
is he is a huge spider-man Stan Lee fan
and all of his friends at the school
there and his family went on social
media and started talking about how they
would like someone to reach out to Stan
Lee if they could and let him know that
this kid was a huge fan and would like
to hear from him it would help him feel
better if he could if he could hear from
him and so it's amazing time we live in
a social media where you can reach out
to someone like a Stan Lee he catches
wind about it and he does something
about it he posted a video this week
addressing Beau and giving him his
heartfelt wishes here's a little piece
of tape Stan Lee the legend man who
created spider-man Fantastic Four
Incredible Hulk America comic books Mark
Twain a living legend the reaching out
to the victim of the shooting from Taft
California hey hi Bo you know I've been
told that you're a big fan of mine and I
want you to know that means a lot to me
so I'm sending you this message to let
you know my thoughts and prayers are
with you as are the thoughts and prayers
of all of Marvel Dome assembled Stan
also sent him a bunch of autographed
posters and comic books and things and a
whole big package of stuff for him to
help them feel better it doesn't have
such an amazing voice great boys
I am bad that voice would make me okay
with my own death what if he if I if he
talked to you to the light oh god yeah
or even if he was just like get down on
the ground
spider-friends you know take your life
if it was coming from that voice I'd be
able to take it I'd be like just say
excelsior when you pull the trigger your
time is over nuff said
apparently Bo and his twin brother
Boehner were very happy with his family
another Hollywood helper this week this
Christian Bale [ __ ] he won't stop he
of course when the Aurora shooting
happened and that's the he went to visit
each and every one of them while they
were in the hospital this week Christian
Bale's took some time out once again
through social media he found out there
was a seven-year-old boy named Zach who
is battling leukemia in the hospital and
he's a huge Batman fan and his family
and friends went on social media and
said they would love for Christian Bale
to reach out if he could
Christian Bale who was in the UK made a
phone call to this kid Zach while he was
in the hospital undergoing treatment and
the parent shot some video it's hard to
hear Christian Bale's end of the
conversation even though it's on
speakerphone but Christian Bale did call
the kid while he was in the hospital and
ask him do you have your own Batmobile
do you have your own Batman costume he
had a cute conversation with this
seven-year-old named Zach here's a
little piece of that conversation we put
it on like one of those little toy cars
uh-huh pretty much real yeah he talked
for about a half an hour he had a
conversation that kid in the hospital
you can tell that's the world go really
cool very nice they said oh you feeling
better
oh good for you good for you you feeling
better we are done professionally Zack
you know we'll never work together again
when he went off on that guy did you
ever hear this is a total psycho ever
hear his apology when he called me at
the radio station and did the apology I
remember you telling me tell the story
Christian Bale was on the set of
terminator it was a three for what
[ __ ] number was it four five six
seven was it cool eight Southbay
salvation no piece of tape was leaked on
the internet of him having a fight with
a guy who was a DP or guests or somebody
he was young at the GP and it went viral
and everybody was talking about the fact
that he went ballistic on this guy and
so on my radio show here in Los Angeles
I was making fun of it a ton and I was
doing that basically every time they
would call Christian Bale on the radio
show you're like oh good for you oh la
dee da da we are done professionally
mate we are done and I would just do
that over and over again for about a
week and then one day I'm about to go on
the air and I get a phone call and say
yeah this is Christian Bale like to have
a conversation with you and then I shat
myself but it turned out he wanted to go
on the air to address the tape and
apologize for what an [ __ ] he sounded
like he was and and explained what had
happened so we put him live on the air
minutes before we were you know the
commercial ran out we had him live on
the air and he talked about it and he
was just like nicest coolest guy in the
world so I always have like a soft spot
in my heart for Christian Bale I think
he's a good guy maybe next week I'll
bring in the tape and we can we can talk
yeah yeah he's like it was inexcusable
mate I was well I was well out of order
it was just not the right thing to do
the wrong wrong place wrong time I just
it was just horrible of me
and I really really really regret it and
I said well you know when you're honest
said you know it's a creative process
tempers flare sometimes people get get
agitated and it's a shame that that was
taken out of context he said oh good for
you you know it's like on a set Nadia
you know we are done professionally so
it didn't really work the whole apology
thing mr. Schmo Oh Joe Schmoe good for
you oh boy I wish some of you [ __ ]
had Nielsen boxes I'll tell you that
much
Ted spike go check it out yeah Tuesday
night since the program that's not like
wrestling the [ __ ] spike that's not
wrestling or MMA or tattooing that's how
you know us every week we take a look at
some excellent actors who occasionally
it happens to the best of us turn in
less than excellent performances it's
called exquisite acting this week's
exquisite acting comes from Hassan from
Mexico he writes the other day I was
watching Star Trek insurrection in that
film it sounds so dirty now
almost as dirty as into the darkness
Star Trek Star Trek
f murray Abraham apparently is the bad
guy in that film I I never saw Stargate
Star Trek insurrection I saw it it's
good he says a flurry Abraham plays a
villain who looks like he's got
somebody's balls stretched over his face
suddenly I was interested in seeing this
film so I wash in the attached clip
hassan writes the oscar-winning thespian
show some exquisite acting the moment
the [ __ ] starts to go wrong for his
character as I mentioned I had never
seen until Hassan recommended it to me
it is a pretty remarkable moment here is
f murray abraham being disappointed as
the villain in Star Trek insurrection
[Music]
jeez hey relax
[Music]
it's my balls on my face I'd be unhappy
too Murray Abraham also every week we
try to take a look at a major motion
picture TV show that has hundreds of
people working around the clock to
ensure the quality that ends up on your
TV or movie screen invariably some [ __ ]
slides between the cracks even in the
biggest of films it is the [ __ ] that
should not be this week's [ __ ] that
should not be comes from Travis Munson
he writes last night I was in my office
where her my wife yelling for me
screaming that she had seen some [ __ ]
that should not be she was watching
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade the
scene was where Indiana and his father
had just settled down to a table on the
blimp my wife Ashley is very proud of
this and she has alluded to the fact
that she may give up the turn the
sheriff's badge if a shout-out is
received so ralph hook a brother up
thanks for all you guys do Travis Munson
that's a long-ass here's the here's the
scene she's talking about I usually
describe what you're about to watch but
I want to see if anyone can catch it
because I've seen this this movie a
dozen times easily maybe more I never
noticed this before until Travis's wife
pointed it out here's the scene she's
talking about if you missed it don't
worry about it cuz I've got a still
store I've got a shot of this scene
she's talking about and we'll pointed
out but here's the scene from Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade
I made it when we're airborne with
Germany behind us then I'll share magic
Thanks
anybody catch what the problem was not
the flowers no not the flowers let's
show the picture can we get the still
story thing Sean Connery is reading a
newspaper that is upside down the entire
time he's open up a newspaper and it's
upside down and he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] and he's just gonna he's just gonna
play the scene and I'm thinking somebody
in the set must have said Spielberg
maybe Sean yeah can we retake that
because the the newspaper was upside
down he said listen to me you [ __ ] I'm
Sean [ __ ] Connery I don't have much
time left on this planet the last thing
I'm going to do is retake a [ __ ]
scene because the paper was upside down
I have an idea
you put the paper right side up then
suck my scottish [ __ ] lifts my kilt and
lick my balls full of scotch
i'm guessing that's why they don't [ __ ]
with Sean every week of course we take a
look you guys are so creative the
listeners of the of the of the Hollywood
babble-on show kevin is he's an icon
that's what he is and when you take them
and you use a little Photoshop and you
stick them where he doesn't belong it
always makes me laugh so we have this
segment called keV in places he doesn't
belong
[Music]
what's Kevin this week well it's a
western-themed this week
I love the westerns Kevin's not a big
fan I've been trying to talk to him to
make one more film
he says he's got one more film in him
I'm trying to make it a Western because
I've always wanted to be in a Western I
want him to put me in one but he says
now he doesn't care for the Western and
I'm surprised given all of the westerns
that Kevin has done over the years let's
take a look at some of them of course
he's in the the hugely popular Golden
Globes winning award-winning Django
Unchained here as the the bounty hunter
hey Lucas playing Django
how hot do I look as a cowboy come on
let's do a Western clerks three the
Western only if we can call the movie
cowpoke
speaking of which Kevin likes sex with
men as was proven in his second
performance in a Western Brokeback
Mountain here he is with the lovely Jake
Gyllenhaal you may not remember this
they changed the poster line after was
initially released but his Brokeback
Mountain it's not gay if you dress like
a cowboy they change that you look good
at the cowboy to the character in the
movie looked like that there's no way
anyone believed they were going fishing
and this isn't technically a Western but
it was included in this week's theme
anyway because it takes place of the Old
West remember Back to the Future 3 where
Doc Brown goes back into the Old West
many who may not remember but Kevin
actually played his creepy son who took
Wentz to his own penis a lot yeah
special need child who is touching his
own penis that doesn't even take your
face look like a bobblehead bad but it
is appropriate response look at that on
the set all right let's take a look at
some of the biggest stories in show
business news this week with the HBO
headlines
[Music]
like like me maybe you were disappointed
as you watch the Golden Globes over last
weekend that watch them of course I
watch really of course
the Hollywood Foreign Press I don't even
know what that means i watch it because
I hope when people are on the red carpet
that somebody's tip will slip out that's
why I watch it I'm hoping for a wardrobe
malfunction that happens I watched the
entire pre-show on the red carpet no
tits and I watched the whole show no
tits and if it turns out I was watching
the wrong part because it was the after
parties that's where the tits started
coming out Eva Longoria apparently was
on the red carpet of one of these
parties when she got her high heeled
tangled in her dress that's can we get a
shot of evil Agora outside here she is
trend trying to fix her dress a little
did she know
oh let's zoom in on that if we can there
we go that's what I'm talking about
her dress popped open and there you go
there's a little Hershey kiss right
there for you that's that's a little
that's a pert little Hispanic breast
right there that's what you got that
right there is why we're double shirts
see you're always smart you know where
the open plunging neckline one might it
falls that's the nightmare yeah here's
the thing I'm an adult man well that's
debatable but in terms of age I'm
certainly an adult man and I have seen
my share of tits I'll be frank and I've
seen a lot of porn and I've seen a lot
of strippers and I've seen a lot of tits
nothing turns me on as much as the
inappropriate tit the stolen tit that
shouldn't be tits that should not be
love I love people in everyday life I
don't care where they are the car wash
at the dry cleaner just went at it shows
up where it shouldn't be nothing gives
me more wood than that that's your
favorite thing it's my favorite thing
nudity where it doesn't belong
inappropriate nudity for me is a huge
turn-on so I don't give a [ __ ] about it
you can have the evil agree a sex tape
and she's just banging 12 gardeners and
I wouldn't care
but she's on the red carpet and she
shouldn't be showing the nipple it comes
out I'm like [ __ ] yeah you become like
the desperate house husband that's me
yeah that's very happy
I like this stolen nudity myself but my
face it's never really the famous people
man it's crazy [ __ ] you just see in real
life out here in Los Angeles that
happens I'm more often than not like
more so than it ever did back in Jersey
man the emoji were driving around one
day we're going up Laurel Canyon and
there's a small line of traffic about
like 15 cars backed up as we got to the
top of the traffic you people were
rubber necking he thought maybe it was
an accident or something
there was this Jeep that was just parked
in the middle of the intersection there
was a chick completely [ __ ] naked
walking around she got into the backseat
and just laid down and we were like what
the [ __ ] is going on man and do you
think she's lonely we didn't see anybody
that awesome we saw dude run around with
a video camera we're like oh they're
shooting porn he doesn't but that point
I said Mosier was drama is like dude
turn around let's go back and he's like
alright and so we drove back and we
[ __ ] saw it again and sure enough she
was naked and she lips and everything
was [ __ ] nuts man I was like Los
Angeles is cool but then I realized we
still have to go back over the hill so I
was like we are time we went [ __ ] it
back up again the third time the chick
like made eye contact like we've done 3
passes like lady put your clothes on now
that we're going home this week
[ __ ] tape star Kim Kardashian was in the
news
James I'm pulling the chain dude we need
the water to hit my test
[Music]
penta controversy this week as Kim and
Kourtney Kardashian went from LAX to JFK
they were flying back and forth from New
York to Los Angeles and on both ends of
their trip they received a police escort
from the airport to where they were
going
mmm your tax dollars at work
yes III pay taxes to the city of Los
Angeles I don't want anyone involved
with the LAPD involved with the
Kardashians unless they're emptying
their clip into them I'll pay for the
bullets gladly with Khloe of course
you're gonna need two or three clips to
get through the the fur to get through
the fur got that [ __ ] Chewbacca coat
but I really should the cops be taking
care of these people I wouldn't agree
with the police escort no not at all I
mean I would imagine if they had to be
put into like the witness relocation
program or protected before that that
would make sense but just for like hey
man they gotta get from a plane to a
[ __ ] hotel they need we all do and
these are people court nothing about
publicity so they can't have a chapped
ass when they show up in the paparazzi
waiting to shoot their pictures they
wouldn't exist if those people weren't
taking their pictures what really pissed
me off was two weeks ago Kim who was
carrying the spawn of Kanye of course as
she was working out of the Jama that she
had to go to Jamba Juice and the cops
escorted her from her gym to the Jamba
Juice to [ __ ] out of yeah they really
they they took care of it here's a shot
take care of her no sadly no here's a
shot Kim at LAX being escorted by a cop
apparently on a hovercraft of some kind
or a Segway or something I'm not sure I
know this high-tech police device is but
it's just it's insane when there's real
crime going on out there that they're
protecting the Kardashians look at her
she's like oh please don't take my
picture please please please you you had
you blew a guy in front of a camera
that's what you did to make yourself
famous
you cannot say now I don't want any to
take my picture I don't think they let
you blow guys at the LA accident no it's
some sort of hell I had I was involved
in one police escort and it was it was
kind of cute we were on the rock can't
say the state where it was because I
won't get anybody in trouble well we're
on the road for the red-state tour and
we went it was after the screening was
done with did the QA and stuff like that
and we'd loaded up into the bus and
we're gonna head out and we're maybe it
was like five ten miles to where we were
going so I think the freeway entrance
and we were gonna be off and running so
the cops who had been there for the
screening outside and stuff they were
leading us there and they were like here
watch this and they turned the lights on
and they gave us like this police escort
man they were swerving the lanes nobody
was out it was 2:00 in the morning and
[ __ ] so it was kind of cute man it was
fun and stuff and my wife starts taking
pictures with her cell phone and stuff
awesome the cops immediately pull over
and stuff come over to the cut to the
bus they knock on the window and they're
just like yeah please don't take
pictures of this this is a huge waste of
taxpayer dollars but again nobody was
around there's more of a joke than
anything all right this is [ __ ] crazy
just thinking had they busted your bus
for pot how much they could have scored
points with the police force they would
have gone like bales and bales of
marijuana had they actually pulled you
over they know more talentless people
making tons of money Britney Spears was
in the news this week there are three
Las Vegas hotels that are currently in a
bidding war for her services they want
her to become their artist in residency
way so like their Celine Dion or Elton
John cher there's a lot of people who go
to Vegas now it will just park
themselves in one hotel and play for a
couple years a couple nights a week and
they make a ton of money Caesars Palace
is one of them a couple other ones are
also talking to Britney Spears the
initial bid for Britney Spears at
Caesars was two hundred million dollars
for a two year deal
100 million dollars a year for two years
four or five performances a night and
also several appearances at some clip or
live per night yeah no no per week I'm
sorry oh [ __ ] I was like she's earning
it now that would be good
she works hard funny how exhausting it
is to lip-sync four or five times a
night I can't imagine now four or five a
week and then she would also have to
make appearances promotional parodies
it's not like that but still a hundred
million dollars a year right in one
place you come out here just lip sync
old old podcasts I think that's the way
to even better man I'll put together my
belly give you the fuzzy navel yeah
right
you [ __ ] it on stage huh people pay to
see that people be like it's amazing
there's a guy thin guy [ __ ] a fat guy
in the belly
lady low hand also in the news this week
[Music]
Lyndsay in trouble again the W Hotel in
New York City said they're still
cleaning up after her last visit really
yeah yeah you do not want to run the
blacklight over Lindsay's suite after
she's been there
$50,000 worth of damage in the suite
that she stayed in how the what is she
[ __ ] doing man is she trying to
summon the beast from hell how do you do
that much damage in the [ __ ] room man
she's like we built the star vaster off
in the floor and we killed a virgin
[ __ ] this once spilt Bacardi and and
still Satan didn't come so I'm sorry can
you add it to the pill management said
she gave all the furniture herpes no
they say she she's somebody's cigarette
burns in the carpet they had to swap out
the carpet in the entire suite because
cigarette burns were all over there I
don't [ __ ] do it
that'll do it yeah fifty thousand
dollars worth of damage from partying
the other story this week was that she
fired her longtime attorney because
attorney tried to make a plea bargain
with the city of Los Angeles regarding
that accident she had last summer where
she plowed into the 18-wheeler what was
the don't put me in jail like Kermit the
Frog girl that went out Lindsay didn't
agree with that tact and so she fired
the attorney saying go in there and
plead not guilty to all the charges so
now she's got to face a trial for these
misdemeanor charges regarding her
accident let's say what he was plea
bargaining for it was just she was gonna
get
reduce charge yes yes she's like
[ __ ] let's take our chances that's
right
Chris problem the cops know what you did
last summer and Lindsay according to her
father how did she pay up for all this
stuff how does she keep herself in the
style in which he's accustomed her
father Michael oh and her father said
this week that she is paid to date rich
old men that's how she's making her
money these days she's working as an
escort about yes the most [ __ ] up well
he made the point of saying she doesn't
have sex with these men
but for cash she will show up he says
these dates last four days the guy's pay
for everything hotel travel costs food
whatever as well as jewelry and other
gifts for Lindsay one of her
high-profile clients is the third in the
line to the throne at Brunei he paid
Lindsay $100,000 to join him in London
on New Year's Eve said Michael Owen but
she doesn't have sex with these men for
money it's just for her company because
she's a joy to be around what is the
legal definitely go the what is the
definition of prostitution sex in
exchange for cash yeah yeah but he says
she doesn't have sex with him she just
spends her company with them I mean I
guess he does not have sex for money yes
sex for cocaine let's get that straight
let's make sure we know the
differentiation between those two
activities this girl needs some [ __ ]
help man somebody told me this week that
she puts a lot a lot of weigh more so
than we joke around going she's always
drunk like she's putting a internally
deadening amount of liquor into her [ __ ]
more than Ralph Garman how dare you sir
believe it somebody needs to look
government that article I we talked
about last time that article was in The
New York Times that talks about her
casting and firing and then rehiring on
that Paul Schrader movie The Canyons
yeah there's a moment or two of human
buoyancy that the writer reveals her to
have still like she seems to be aware of
the fact that everything's [ __ ]
crumbling around her and although she
says she's trying just hapless [ __ ]
happenstance after happenstance she gets
herself in so much trouble
it's a shame though man cuz again I
maintain that maintain from beginning
she's talented actors she's really good
well she used to be I haven't seen her
do anything lately that confirms that
for me though that's just sad like
[ __ ] and her this is what breaking to
me is her father going like oh yeah she
gets paid to [ __ ] date it's like who
[ __ ] says that about their daughter
even if it's true shouldn't he'd be like
oh my god date an old guy for a hundred
grand the third and line for [ __ ]
that Brunei you're out of your mind
instead he's out there gone yeah yeah
yeah she does everything shy of suck the
guy off no wonder she's in the [ __ ]
place she is that's her [ __ ] father
yeah her parents are a mess yeah nobody
looked out for this [ __ ] kid nobody's
still looking out for it's a shame I
mean I know we make a lot of jokes about
her and [ __ ] but it's just so yeah hey
by the way my back shut up like 20
minutes out of our act if she stops
being an [ __ ] no that gets burned
remember where your bread is buttered
sir
there's no room for Humanity in this
show Megan Fox did interview with
Esquire magazine this week where she
talked about her youth as well she
talked about the fact that now she's an
actress she's very successful but she
was raised at Pentecostal when she was
living in Tennessee and she said that
when she was in church when she was a
young person she would speak in tongues
she would go to church and the energy
would be so strong words would just
start coming out of my mouth she said
much like the transformer movies
but she said people couldn't comprehend
what I was saying much like the
transformer movies
she says it's what spoken in heaven only
God understands it regarding what she
would say in church you're so cute yes
it is that's the language in heaven
usually do you talk to yeah it's not the
language it makes when she's servicing
is when she is there you know we haven't
talked about in a while because she
retired she hasn't been much on the
scene is Amanda Bynes
[Music]
amanda bynes retired from show business
until this week when she realized that
nobody was [ __ ] talking about her
anymore so she went on Instagram and she
showed off her latest attention-getting
gimmick which is getting her face
pierced yeah you heard me she got her
face pierced we got that shot from
Instagram of her with her new chin
piercing or cheek piercing leash if you
had a diamond stud driven through her
cheek and there it is America speaks
don't have a doctor who looked at the
picture said such a piercing can ruin
the facial appearance of a person yeah
no [ __ ] yeah America said this guy
sounds like [ __ ] hi everybody I'm dr.
NIC if you put an earring in your face
it will ruin your appearance I managed
that she didn't do it for attention she
did it because she's proud of her
ability to show off her tolerance for
pain
I'd like to see her getting an MMA ring
then if that's the case and catch a
couple punches Michael J Fox is on our
side when it comes to Tait offs whittler
the spawn of Satan during the Golden
Globes there was a joke made by Tina Fey
that she said two tails Tay Tay tops
whittler stay away from Michael J Fox
his son he was one of the people on
stage handing out awards they always
have the sons and daughters
someone came up to Michael J Fox and
said after the awards would you approve
of Taylor Swift dating your son Sam
who's 23 he said no no no just back off
he said I don't keep up with it all but
Taylor Swift write songs about everybody
she goes out with right what a way to
build a career Michael J Fox said the
interviewer then asked Michael if Swift
showed up to a Fox family dinner what
his reaction would be he said I wouldn't
even know who she was but then I would
hear the eventual song in the radio like
Sam you're a piece of [ __ ] and go oh
that was the girl you brought home for
dinner
so the nicest guy on television is
slamming Taylor Swift I love that guy
you know he's gonna have a new series on
NBC a new sitcom where he's playing
essentially with a guy who's suffering
from Parkinson's trying to keep his
career and family together
hope they have a laugh track a new movie
in the works based on the life and times
of Penn State football coach Joe Paterno
yeah
no tickets sold in this room it's going
to be made by Brian De Palma the
director and his co-star he's gonna team
up rather with his co-star of Carlito's
Way and Scarface Al Pacino will be
playing Joe Paterno in the film's
actually pretty good casting man if you
look at him when he played Jack
Kevorkian on that HBO series and you
look at Joe Paterno there's a lot of
similarities he can do he can really
crank himself and hunched over and stuff
physically Oh
oh yeah I can play Joe Paterno come on
now with the showers with the boys oh
you shouldn't have sex with boys but I'm
gonna look over here and not report you
cause that's football
oh it's a little teaser for two with
every good movie I'm looking forward to
like the paterno movie there's a movie
that will suck on the horizon
couple movies that will suck yeah
this week was announced that Tyler Perry
has announced wait for it you might like
it
a Madea Christmas see I was right here
you've changed your minds a Madea
Christmas is the story of Madea who goes
to a small town to visit a friend for
the holidays the cast has been firmed up
a Kathy Najimy Lisa Whelchel of the
facts of life and Larry the Cable Guy
will be co-starring it's the perfect
storm of a movie it might be so bad it
comes all the way around to [ __ ] that
last media movie didn't make any money
it didn't really and no one went to see
Madea is Alex Cross the vampire
detective or whatever the [ __ ] that
movie was the Madea mysteries the father
Madea mysteries yes and Jerry Lewis has
announced he's making a new movie at 86
years old he's making a drama called max
Rose of the story of a jazz pianist who
lost his wife of 50 years and goes into
a deep deep depression well that's what
we've all been waiting for is it's Jerry
Lewis playing a depressed jazz pianist
Jerry says this will be the maybe the
final starring role of his career fair
assumption I 86 man yeah I would have to
say let me tell you something I played
piano for a long time and now my wife
was dead and she was a great lady
but she's gone now and let me tell you
something else when you walk through a
storm hold your head up high
little trees are for the full weight
suddenly into Max roses life yes Joe
Paterno Wow oh I got to tell you max I
feel your pain your wife had a great ass
thank you Joe Paterno you're a nice guy
Hawaii with the people in the
wheelchairs with the kids for you that's
what they should have done combine the
two and lastly a woman in New York and a
fitness guru has decided to develop an
entire workout plan based on the book
fifty Shades of Grey
this book just won't [ __ ] die no it
is called 50 shapes of gray and each of
the 13 different exercises she promised
will not only make you leaner and more
toned but Micah come no because then
I'll get fat it will make you better in
bed lotions it will make you better in
bed if you listen to these exercises
[Applause]
exercises like the bend over better is
one of the exercises these sexy scissors
it's for the lesbian members of the
audience and the seductive squat you
love the Selective squat I'm glad you
liked that one sir because that's the
video I brought in for you this little
piece of the workout video lose the
workout video fifty shapes of gray
here's the seductive squat
I want to show you is this adaptive
squad let's close out I want you to
squat down thrust your hips under
release and lift back up it's already
working get fifty shapes up then all
right Ken and I are both geeks that's
why we get excited every week for the
news about geeks problem is I did one on
my way to get to the sexy scissors oh
[ __ ] that she'd be like I'm gonna tie up
with an excellent [ __ ] off this hurts
little bein in that exercises are
irritating to be
[Applause]
[Music]
this week in the geek news hockey's back
we're all very excited about that no
more so than this gentleman in the great
country of Canada who put together a
hockey game between super heroes and
super villains to celebrate the return
of the NHL I saw this and to be fair the
guy dressed like Batman the fact that he
could [ __ ] score goal dressed like
that's pretty important yes spider-man
scores two for the heroes of
spider-man's costume he's got no [ __ ]
cape it's like running around your
underwear Batman you're dealing with a
cowl a pelvis it's got no pads either
spider-man has no pads Eva don't matter
if your sleek man let's say you're like
Bobby Orr and you can't get hit or
something like that you're just moving
around too [ __ ] nice Batman's wearing
a cumbersome outfit and he was still
able to [ __ ] score I beg to differ I
think spider-man is much more impressive
or a marvel zombie here's a little piece
of video from the great white north of
the superheroes playing the super
villains and some hockey to celebrate
the return of the NHL Joker versus
Jubilee the Joker looks good doesn't
fade
there's fighting yeah
[Music]
yeah that's my boy right there I don't
want to i watch the whole thing I don't
want to spoil it but it's cute at one
point [ __ ] Bane gets into a fight
with Batman does break his spine yeah I
also do want to mention that available
right now is a knight 1939 I said 2013
calendar called the women of geekdom
these are all official female gifts in
here all along mr. calm and well Lloyd
the women of geekdom of 2013 it's a
calendar that features females who are
actual geeks celebrating all things geek
and they are lovely and each page of
each month is a beautiful girl in a
different geek oriented costume a lot of
the proceeds from the sales of this
calendar are going to the Wayne
Foundation which I know is a charity
which is very near and dear to you right
yeah it celebrates helping women who are
a victim of domestic sex trafficking a
lot of the proceeds from this calender
go to that cause so I did want to give a
shout out the people who are doing the
women of geekdom 2013 counter you can go
to women of geekdom dot-com if you want
to get the calendar here's a couple
pictures of the girls who are featured
this is one of the girls here in a
typical superhero costume she's one of
the months we have another girl who's
dressed up as Doctor Who yeah that's
what I'd like to get inside her TARDIS
you know what I'm saying Wow I bet it's
bigger on the inside you know what I'm
saying
Sonic's crew Germany
he turns the greatest biggest selling
porn movie in the world right now is a
porn parody called Superman vs.
spider-man
it's the biggest selling porn movie in
the country right now it's crazy it's
way way sir
people love to see our superheroes from
our childhood having sex of course well
we've all dreamed about it is called
Superman vs. spider-man it is by Vivid
Entertainment the people who are gonna
do clerks xxx wait Superman spider-man
no they it's like a fuck-off it's like
they're each [ __ ] different people
and whoever [ __ ] the most wins remember
the old crossover comic book yeah it's
based on that but instead of fighting
crime
it's jism here's a scene from the the
most popular porn movie in the country
right now this is spider-man and
spider-woman that's a that's that's um
we all thought about at some point
didn't we
no come on only when he was hanging
upside down in the movie well there were
better pictures that I really didn't
feel comfortable showing but you should
see spider-man and Mary Jane
spider-man's not I mean Superman and
Mary Jane spider-man's not gonna be
happy with what happens there trust me
it's just Peter Parker [ __ ] Lois Lane's
boilers I think it's I think it's only
fair don't you I guess
now a man ma'am intrigued where's the
story go super swingers now you're
involved
and while return is just like I'm gonna
take the bottle of Kandor up my ass all
the kandorians are like the Sun is going
away oh shut up
hey wait do we have a shirt tonight
does anybody know I think we have a
shirt there's before you leave remember
last week I was telling you about the
t-shirt punch make shirts we have a
shirt this week that looks like to keep
calm carry on carry on thing and it says
where is it there it is there it is come
on oh it's [ __ ] dope man I just want
to shout out before y'all leave but
there's only like 25 room so grab them
before they're gone and another
housekeeping thing I want to take care
of as well as we're gonna be not here
next week no we won't
we're gonna be in Halifax Nova Scotia
don't you know doing a little bit of
s'more g-man on Saturday so we were not
gonna be here and then are we here the
next week or yes we reg we're here in
February 2nd yeah okay and then there's
a week after that why are we here but
space monkeys are gonna be here - after
thank you yeah there's a podcast of my
friends - Brian Johnson from comic book
men Brian Quinn from from Impractical
Jokers on true - they do a podcast those
dudes are from Tom Steve David they do a
podcast without Walter called space
monkeys and they're coming to town so we
do the 8 o'clock show and they do the 10
o'clock show and then we go to Long
Beach one week as well
yes as well [ __ ] bring your friends
[ __ ] yeah right it's nice little
housekeeping back to you sir and while
we're talking about superheroes [ __ ]
and stuff this this artist named Greg
Gilman easy he's a really talented guy
he has put together a series of prints
that are available now for sale I don't
get any of this I just wanted to give
you a heads up it's called the secret
life of superheroes and I just thought
it was really funny what he did it's
it's the stuff that we always think
about with superheroes that you never
see them do like they have to do
everything that we do because they're
they're human for the most part like
like Batman for example you never see
him brushing his teeth but this guy puts
together a portrait of Batman brushing
his teeth with how it was cool that's
like Superman when Superman has a Booker
what happens if Superman has a book
breathes and who else is gonna get it
out put him know exactly if he clenches
his nostril who snap your finger up no
one else can dig for gold but Superman
and even even Wonder Woman once in a
while wonder one has to be able has to
relieve herself right I mean well that's
kind of hot yeah yeah I would say tied
me up with the golden lasso and they'd
give me a golden shower that's what I
would say we just saw a little too much
into the psyche of Ralph Garman I'm Alan
every week we like to talk about the
size of Liam Neeson's [ __ ] we can't help
but were fascinated and so we asked this
musical question
[Music]
[Music]
that was like one of those movies where
the sandbag comes down and she didn't
carry I thought it was gonna be pig's
blood next and you're gonna start
setting the place on fire it was Phantom
of the Opera shoots I'm just trying to
kill us
sorry about that normally the [ __ ] grows
but it [ __ ] crowed on that what am i
[ __ ] flying man I got away from me
like a salmon we talked about the size
of Liam Neeson Scott and you our good
listeners always go to nice and calm and
add your own facts about the size of the
[ __ ] it's a place you go there nice
decent [ __ ] calm nice and [ __ ] calm and
these are the top 10 facts about Liam's
[ __ ] this week Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big
Huell Howser died trying to describe it
that's a guy who could describe some
[ __ ] that's true man that is amazing
it's so big see if I can pull this
helmet off on Mars
like Total Recall Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big the internet checks it every day
[Laughter]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that two
separate keys must be inserted into each
of his balls and turned simultaneously
to activate it yeah Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that if you're going to visit
it you probably want to get the season
pass because you can't see it all in one
day it's true I got about halfway
through I had to just stop at the food
court totally I get to the bug in the
base of the balls I'm like give me a
three churros
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it has a
night watchman probably armed Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it has an auto
self-destruct protocol in case it should
fall into enemy hands who initiates the
sequence Auto self-destruct sequence
listen to me you're about to be taken
with Janice Dickinson gets her hands on
it Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Jenny
McCarthy insists to give kids autism oh
come on that's [ __ ] funny oh thank
you for turning around we should stop
there but I won't Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big that Liam doesn't need to take
any clubs to play golf but he does need
three caddies Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it Framed Roger Rabbit and shot
junior and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big he produces more Irish cream than
Bailey's
[Applause]
[Music]
people of Hollywood's a good time this
evening as always we can't thank you
enough for spending your Saturday night
with us I'd like to give it up for my
amazing host man the guy who does it all
give it up for Ralph Garman and please a
warm round of applause for my good
friend and partner mr. Kevin Smith and
that is Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
out of a fuck-off good night everybody
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time for Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
Hollywood babble-on live at the Lovett
[Applause]
you